agents we've recovered five more
hostages that were taken during the
attack on the White House including
Vic's sister birdie who has vital Intel
on the black tusks infrastructure and
systems and Net's plans for the mobile
shd servers as it was birdie who was
tasked with building and maintaining
their power supply however it was
through this rescue that another layer
of Deceit was uncovered agent Brian
Johnson was unmasked as the recruiter
Johnson used his position as your
Handler to hide Intel that was uncovered
and was almost successful in stealing
the mobile shd server the Revelation
that Hunters walk among the agents
further divides the already fragmented
division ranks and Vic questions who
else could be a hunter and points the
finger at Kelso Manny refuses to believe
that Kelo is a hunter however we are
unable to clear her name at this stage
because she has gone missing agents we
need to find Kelo and uncover what she
has been doing in New
[Music]
York